不能说我穷，
我没钱，
所以该给别人的钱我不给了，
不能吧，
这是该给妹妹读大学，
该给妹妹付这个钱呀，
这个妹妹该有的钱呀，
该是到妹妹手里的钱呀，
不能这么不讲道理啊，
我的婚姻有没有必要继续？
事情的起因的话，
就是我老公和姐姐要求平摊他们同父异母的妹妹的大学的费，
然后我老公就是想都没想就直接答应了。
他的情况的话是他自己欠了几十个外债和几十个外债，
有银行的10个，
有他姐姐了20个，
我们的孩子明年要上小学了，
但是还没有房子，
也没有户口，
在幼儿园用钱也很厉害，
因为他情况比较特殊嘛，
他是一个发育迟缓的孩子，
用钱也很厉害，
但是他每次面对这些事情的时候都是无脑的，
听他姐姐的话，
之前的话他都是小付出，
包括她妹妹高中的费用也是他们那个平摊的，
就是我都没有说什么，
但是大学的话费用很高，
包括每个月生活费也很高，
你公公婆婆是干啥的呀？
我公公婆婆去世了，
公公是去年去世的，
她现在的话有一个后妈，
这个妹妹呢，
是当后妈生的哦，
后妈是干啥的呀？
后妈在餐厅里面当服务员，
之前没有在餐厅里面当服务员的时候，
她的后妈的生活费也是她们两姐妹承担。
他了，
我都没有说什么，
我觉得没什么，
但是这一次的话，
我真的觉得他一直无脑的偏袒，
他们都从来没有为我跟小孩子考虑过，
公公去世了之后，
留下什么遗产没有啊，
留下了那一个22万的保险，
直接就继承给我老公了嘛，
但是要他80岁的时候才能把这个钱取出来，
每一年有一个5000的收益，
那其他两个，
一个姐姐一个妹妹有没有继承公公什么财产啊？
他跟他姐姐两个继承了20万，
然后每个人10万，
那抚养妹妹不是应该的吗？
照理来说妹妹也有继承的资格，
为啥不给妹妹啊？
因为他妹妹还没成年，
所以就他妹妹那部分是他们代持的，
对呀，
那就拿那部分代持的钱去供他读大学不行吗？
但是现在他自己的小孩子也很需要钱啊，
不是咱得讲道理呀，
姐妹，
本来人家那个妹妹有一份的呀，
只不过被你的老公和你老公的姐姐平摊了呀，
拿走了呀，
照理来说的话，
他们三姊妹，
包括人家那个老太太，
这后妈也是有份额的呀，
假设啊，
这老头有40万的存款，
首先撇出来，
20万是人家那个老太太的呀，
那夫妻共同财产呀，
剩下的20万是他们四个人再来平分呀，
人家这个妹妹分到的钱足以上大学呀，
是人家这个妹妹该有的呀，
现在姐姐实之下，
让姐姐和这个哥哥来出这个上大学的钱，
这也何其何。
对呀，
就是说你们情况困难是你们的事儿，
但是从道理上来说的话，
从他的爸爸那里继承得到的这个财产，
足以覆盖人家妹妹读大学的这个钱呀，
那他自己的小孩子明年就要上小学了，
你自己的孩子是你们两口子自己得去挣呐，
你们两口子自己得去挣钱呀，
他分的那个钱，
因为创业的话已经全部环境里经胖了，
他也没有钱了，
你不能说我穷我没钱，
所以该给别人的钱我不给了，
不能吧，
这是该给妹妹读大学，
该给妹妹付这个钱呀，
这个妹妹该有的钱呀，
但是到妹妹手里的钱呀，
不能这么不讲道理啊，
他是从他妹妹小学的时候，
他们两姐妹就一直在平摊他妹妹的费用，
那这样说的话，
她妈妈也应该承担她妹妹的，
当然，
但是妹就是默认了，
她妈妈没有任何这种，
不是说没有责任不用出，
是他们两姊妹看到这个后妈确实没有能力，
确实没有本事，
他后妈有二十几万的存款呀，
关键是那也应该出一部分啊，
那这是各差的，
一直就是就默认了，
他后妈就一分钱都不用出，
他妹妹初中高中的生活费学费都是他们两个姐妹出的，
我就是心里有一点不平衡了点，
但是这个评论我也看了，
他们说的有道理，
他跟他姐姐的经济差距是非常大的，
他姐姐年收入有30~50万，
但是她。
不在30万，
我理解你啊，
作为一个妈妈，
作为一个母亲，
看到孩子要读书，
又没有房子，
又没有户口，
又没有存款，
我理解你的这种担忧和焦虑，
但是很多东西的话，
做人得讲道理，
这个道理就是哪怕他姐姐再挣钱，
这也是他姐姐的本事，
不能因为说她姐姐姐夫能挣钱，
所以什么责任都甩给姐姐和姐夫不管，
是从情理上来说，
从法律上来说的话，
你的丈夫确实是第一继承了10万块钱，
第二那个20万的保单也是你丈夫继承的，
虽然说这个可能保单他有一个延后性，
可能10年、
20年，
多少年之后才能够取这个钱，
但他确实是有经济利益和价值的，
你老公也继承了这个是不是？
我看评论区说把钱还给他，
但是这个钱我一分都没拿到啊，
不是你还啊，
你老公该承担该出这个钱，
这个妹妹是同父异母，
也就是说跟你的老公是有血缘关系的，
所以说你老公拿了这个钱是还他的债了，
但这个钱的性质并没有发生变化，
这个钱的性质就是其中有一部分钱是代为持有的，
你不能说张三把这个钱交到你手上，
麻烦你帮忙保管一下，
然后这个钱就变成你的了，
这个逻辑是不对的，
就是说你老公得到的这10万块钱，
其中有一部分是代为持。
有，
这钱并不是你老公的，
你老公又去还他的债了，
但是这笔钱的性质并没有变化，
他还是帮他的妹妹代为持有的，
还有啥问题呀？
好吧，
我都看出去为已经懂啊，
好，
那就这样好，
拜拜，
记得点赞关注哦。